the cthulhu mythos is a combination of
many books written by many different
authors aside from the great hp
lovecraft himself
as by his wishes he left the cthulhu
universe as an open book
for competent writers to fill in the
gaps and expand the franchise
this timeline is based on canonical
books like the timeline of the cthulhu
mythos
the challenge from beyond by moore where
yethera walks by the bill
just to name a few in this video we
shall only showcase the most important
events in the timeline
especially the ones that date back
millions or billions of years ago
and the ones which are proposed to
extend millions of billions of years in
the future
modern human interactions or birth dates
are omitted as it will
just be too confusing taking into
account the variety of books and works
by many authors
so here goes the timeline 13.8 billion
years ago
the universe is created in the big bang
since it is said that we live in the
dreams of the outer god as a doth
therefore it is also the time when the
idiot god himself
went into his deep eternal slumber 4.5
billion years ago
the planet earth is formed around the
star called saul
and this is the third rocky planet
around the sun
four billion years ago yidra is an outer
god who is worshiped as a beautiful
awesome and terrible earth mother
and she comes into being at the same
time the first signs of life on earth
arises
three billion years ago the yacubians
which are a race of worm creatures whom
invade worlds and exchange their minds
with native lifeforms
sends one of their mind transformation
cubes to the milky way galaxy
two billion years ago originally from a
dimension very different from our own
shaknor fawn or the horror elephant god
travels to earth
and creates a race of humanoid beings
one billion years ago the elder things
arrive on earth
they land in the antarctic ocean and
found their first cities there
the other things create the
proto-shoghoth a protoplasm being that
in turn produces other creatures
that acts as servitors and food for the
elder things
900 to 800 million years ago by this
time the elder thing cities have spread
all across the oceans of earth
and have even adapted to living on land
but most of them remain in the oceans
however
750 million years ago the flying polyps
arrive on earth and build their basal
towers on the land
they then try to expand into the oceans
therefore sparking a bitter war
with the elder things however in the end
the other things
emerged victorious 450 million years ago
as the elder things rule supreme on
earth they start to experiment on life
forms
and develop the first vertebrates which
are fish and they
are allowed to evolve 400 million years
ago
the great rays of yidd fleeing
catastrophe from their home world
transmit their minds to a race of
cone-shaped creatures on earth
they then drive the flying polyps on the
ground and imprison them there
370 million years ago as the other
things allow the amphibians to evolve
and arise on earth
chocolate fawn the horror elephant god
later creates the miri nigri
from amphibian flesh as a servator race
350 million years ago cthulhu and his
skin arrived from the star zorth
the elephants then went to war with
cthulhu but they eventually make peace
kazulu keeps his current surface
territories
and the other things keep the rest of
the planet and at the same time the deep
ones
swear that allegiance to cthulhu 320
million years ago
reptiles arose around this time during
the carboniferous period
yik who is the father of serpents and a
half anthropomorphic great old one
was probably involved with the reptile
evolution
300 million years ago a cosmic cataclysm
which is possibly a certain
configuration of the stars
possibly a war with the elder gods
occurs resulting in aarlee
the city of cthulhu sinking beneath the
waves kazulu is imprisoned within the
city
in all likelihood the other great old
ones are imprisoned around the same time
275 million years ago serpent people
arise and found the kingdom called
volusia
they had an advanced culture of science
and sorcery and are capable of
impersonating any humanoid life form at
will
160 million years ago the migo
which are an extraterrestrial species
from the planet ugoth
are probably pluto they are winged
creatures with large claws
and heads covered in antenna the migo
are scientifically
and technologically advanced race and
during that time they win a battle
against the other things
above the planet earth hundred fifty
million
years ago the great rays of yid which
was serpents foil a yuccubian
invasion attempt the yakubians are a
race of warm creatures
whom invade worlds and exchange their
minds with those of the natives
in a manner similar to the great race of
yitz itself
100 million years ago the elder things
built huge cities
both on the water and on dry land they
may be responsible for the appearance of
the first life forms on earth before
but at this time their technological
advancements
led them to their golden age 65 million
years ago
a huge media hit the earth and the
dinosaurs are wiped out
how disaffected or is connected to the
alien races
on the planet is still unknown 50
million years ago
another cataclysm strikes earth and in
the crisis the flying polyps escape
and take revenge on the great rays of
yet which sends
its greatest minds or two bodies on the
planet jupiter
from jupiter the great rays proceed to
bodies similar to their earthly ones
on a world orbiting a dark star on
taurus
six million years ago a member of a race
of insect philosophers which hail from
the fourth moon
of jupiter exchanges mines with one of
the great
rays of yet five million years ago
the serpent people of the city of yacht
an underground kingdom below the present
day
united states flourishes at this time
under the guidance of their god yig
they even created seven species like the
savage humanoid vurmis
but yachts is destroyed by yak when the
serpent people turn to worship another
god called satogwa
three million years ago the savage
humanoid boomers
gained their freedom from the serpent
people they then create a kingdom on the
surface of hyperborea
a conan in the arctic region and they
based on the worship of the great old
one called satogwa
two million years ago as the elder thing
civilization continues to decline
they retreat to their cities on the
southernmost tip of south america
and the antarctic regions 1.7 million
years ago
itakua one of the great old ones and who
looks like a horrifying giant
with a roughly human shape and glowing
red eyes appears in the northernmost
regions of earth resulting in the
decline of the population of the vurmis
one million years ago the ice age is
brought about by the combined powers
of the itaqua and the afumzah who is
also a great old one similar to kathuga
the vermis civilization in hyperborea is
destroyed
and then gradually replaced by humans
and day two suffered in the ice age
750 000 years ago the great polar
civilizations finally fall
the elder things retreat to deep within
the earth
at the same time the human civilization
in hyperborea splinters
and its surviving people scatter across
the planet
five hundred thousand years ago homo
sapiens of modern humanity arises
these earliest true humans found the
kingdom of nematus
and went to war for a thousand years
with the dragon kings
the humans win over the serpent people
and the exiled serpent people form
a second kingdom of valusia 393 thousand
years ago
lemuria a hypothetical lost land located
in either the indian ocean or the
pacific ocean
is shattered by volcanic eruptions
leaving only that
which ultimately becomes hyboria some
survivors flee
and found the first empire of atlantis
two hundred thousand years ago the human
kingdom in mu
reaches its height at this time the
people of mew worship many dark gods
including ghatanathawa yathaktha
and zoth omok all of which are great old
ones and connected to cthulhu
50 000 bc a race of great-headed brown
people
dominate southern africa one of their
generals
is among those who exchange their minds
with one of the great rays of the
ethiopians
24 000 bc the city of the golden gates
the capital of the second kingdom of
atlantis sings beneath the waves as a
result of dark magic
this event also devastates much of the
atlantean continent
20 000 bc at this time
many great countries have arisen in the
barbaric thurian continent
the survivors of lemuria and atlantis
have degenerated into barbarians
and around this time the serpent
people's volusia was taken over by
humans
18000 bc a great cataclysm destroys the
old world
bringing the hyborian age and at this
time
the little yoga which are of vortices of
living power
completely invisible except on occasions
when they appear reptilian came from
andromeda and settled in lemuria and mu
they then used humans as slaves 10 000
bc
this was the time of conan the barbarian
and the simerian barbarian tribes have
wiped out the last serpent people in
their hiborian city called
yan yoga it was also then that a final
cataclysm
destroys the hiborian world and raises
new landmasses moving the world into
more or less its modern configuration
in later times this event is remembered
as the great flood
5000 bc to 500 bc
the ancient kingdoms and civilizations
that are known to most of humanity
rise and fall they include egypt
in northern africa sumeria in the middle
east
the indus civilizations in pakistan and
india
and also the mayan civilizations in
south america and later ones like the
greek civilizations
the romans and so on 300 bc
the pigs which have been around for
almost 20 000 years are shattered into
several smaller tribes
that feud amongst themselves which lead
to their decline and loss of power
200 bc theoretics a greco-bacterial
official
is among those that exchanged their
minds with one of the great rays of the
yetians
between 82 bc and 75 bc
during this time of the roman dictator
sula a question named titus semperonius
blazes
is among one of those that exchanged
their minds with one of the great rays
of the atheians
zero bc till 2018 this is the modern
history of man and of course the rise
and fall of countless human kingdoms
empires and states of course there was
innumerable dabbling with witchcraft
summoning of the great
old ones and the occasional encounters
with members of other species
however modern humanity continued to
thrive
and forget the ancient past filled with
gruesome horror and cosmic beings
two thousand three hundred and fifty ad
fathogwa
the king region of the five vampires
appears as a great flickering ball
of cold blue flame he lives with his
servants
within an enormous edifice upon the
surface of a blue
comet and its fire vampires are due to
arrive on earth during this year
the far future around 8 million a.d
the time of zothik the last continent of
earth
and home to the dying remnants of the
human race
the culture is on a barbaric level and
magic has become dominant over science
50 million a.d following the final end
of humanity
a new race of beetle-like insects arise
these are possessed by
the great race of the ethios leaving
their previous home on a planet orbiting
a dark star near taurus
500 million a.d the first primitive life
develops on venus
one venusian is one among those that
exchanged their minds with the great
rays of the ethios
and as you remember the great rays of
the indians are the ones
developed by the god yig and this is
the last time that any creature from the
solar system exchanges their mind with
this great race
the further future 1 billion a.d
the last inhabitants of earth a species
of arachnids
live within the interior of this dying
world that orbits a red giant star
the sun had become
the unknown future as a thought the
blind god
awakes from his slumber and then the
universe
just ceases to be and with that we come
to the end of the timeline
so be sure to subscribe for more monster
videos and do like
and share our videos